es porque ya conocemos el logo
justamente a los juegos de los ángeles
en 2028 bueno era la apuesta de la
organización con este logo se trata de
una imagen dinámica con 26 diseños
distintos para presentar la variedad y
la inclusión de la ciudad y luego
consiste en una base fija con una letra
que cambia para estar en continua
actualización ante los 8 años que aún
quedan para esta cita olímpica estos
distintos diseños que estamos viendo
fueron creados por figuras de renombre
que son o que viven en los ángeles tales
como la atleta alex son félix o como la
cantante billy hay les entraremos
también acompañado este reporte de las
imágenes de la ciudad de los ángeles que
como decimos va a albergar esta cita
olímpica después de la de 2024 que será
en parís